here is patrick mahomes coincidentally
topic that we've well let's talk about
his toe first yeah let's talk about his
toe and then we'll get into the topic we
discussed yesterday his toe his foot he
was in a walking boot 16 days ago
alarmed a lot of people easter photo
with child yeah mother of child patrick
holmes walking boot and then four days
later out of the walking boot he
explained yesterday that he's now fully
and completely out of the walking boot
and he should be good to go by the end
of the off season program and that's
fine look hey
injury surgery rehab recovery
the the real issue is can they avoid him
having to run around as much as he did
last year to avoid an injury like that
from happening again because i get the
feeling it was something chronic yeah
not something that just kind of happened
one day well i mean
i i don't know about that you feel like
there was something that was bothering
him even before that cleveland game
where it really happened
i i think that
as somebody who used to run a lot and
that is one thing i continue to make
time to do it's just called getting up
before everyone else in the house gets
up and going out and running right you
if you you you a lot repetitive
repetitive yes there's no doubt that and
i i could see that that started just as
there were in those shoes that just
those cleats that just hurt like hell
and you're doing that all the time and
you're and you're running and running
and running because the offensive line
isn't blocking it wouldn't surprise me
if it was something that
started as just a minor irritation
observation and progressively got worse
and then went in the cleveland game yeah
right right i wouldn't be shocked that's
a lot of that's how that injury you know
works a lot of the times and you're
right it usually is because of like not
just one thing it's the residuals of
every day in practice jamming your foot
in the ground and in the game doing all
that and like you said in cleats where
most guys in the nfl wear cleats that
are a little too small for their feet
that they would not actually walk around
in public with that size shoe but they
want to feel faster and quicker so they
wear tighter cleats that jam their their
toes in there even more but you know all
in all listen we know how this is a
serious injury i can't really say like
you know and mike i'll ask you just off
the top of your head i don't remember a
quarterback really dealing with this
type of injury that i can remember at
least in any time you know in the in in
recent history but left foot big toe
right the biggest thing is going to be
for a guy like that dropping back moving
around the pocket you know throwing the
football i don't know if that's
necessarily going to bother him a whole
lot but this is a delicate injury and
it's one you really got to take take
your time and be slow with and make sure
it gets back to
totally a hundred percent it's not one
of those things where you go well hey
it's feeling pretty good it's about 80.
let me start going out there and moving
and doing things that's how you could
set it back ruin your career do whatever
there so uh i i would think he is being
very careful with this and doing his due
diligence before he does anything
aggressive athletically to make sure he
doesn't have these setbacks
and then you got to find a way to get
yourself and keep yourself in the proper
cardiovascular shape so you're not
boxing that's tough that regard yeah
because you can't do
the things that you would ordinarily get
that conditioning from you got to find
other ways to get your conditioning
riding a bike whatever the case may be
but you got to be conscious of that look
it clearly was a serious injury because
three days after the super bowl
he had surgery right they were ready to
go right but let's we gotta get through
this season get through this super bowl
and then we're gonna cut that thing
apart and we're gonna fix it that's how
bad it was so yeah this is a big deal
and i would be concerned moving forward
for a variety of reasons about the
quality of the offensive line but
this patrick can run for his life and
make things happen approach yeah has one
potential flaw which is as he runs for
his life he could eventually get himself
injured by the mere act of running
around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports